when you are thirteen and a half years
old you need to be learning negative
numbers when you are 14 you need to be
learning exponent that's silly
you need to be learning exponents once
you really understand multiplication and
you'd be learning a negative numbers
once you really understand the number
line once you get rid of the stigman you
open it up and everyone's a learner and
everyone's just on the same playing
field it actually is empowering for
everyone I have a two-year-old son Imran
and and and obviously I care about what
his academic experience is going to look
like and I'm hoping that when he's five
or six she goes to a classroom that not
only has five or six year olds in it but
it has kids of all ages in that one
classrooms kind of a reversion back to
the one-room schoolhouse and when he
goes to that classroom some part of his
day and I'm not talking about the whole
day maybe twenty to thirty minutes of
the day especially for the core subjects
are spent on the Khan Academy watching
videos and by that time it won't just be
mathematics and science it'll be grammar
it'll be vocabulary of this orange line
he starts at the most basic concept he
doesn't move on to more advanced
concepts until he shows that he is a
hundred and ten percent proficient and
some more basic ones and then it moves
him on and he gets data and he gets
feedback and his teachers get feedback
and the paradigm is all of these
students at all different ages they're
all going to be working at their own
pace in every class in grammar and
mathematics and everything the teacher
now instead of having to give this
one-size-fits-all lectured everybody can
now look at the data see where every
student is and the software identifies
who's stuck the teacher every now and
then will sit next to him or on and help
him run as a mentor actually had that
human interaction and even better if the
teacher is in tirana even if the teacher
is around it might be better for Imran
to be tutored by one of his peers maybe
another six year old maybe a ten year
old who's a little ahead of the curve
who is well respected as a teacher
already I mean what's really exciting
about this is an interactive experience
I cringe at the idea of my son in a room
at the same rooms that I used to sit in
sitting like this staying at the clock
waiting for the bell to ring I don't
want him to do that for 12 years I want
him interacting with his peers I want
him teaching his peers I want my son to
be respected in his classroom not
because he's he got a perfect on his
SATs not because he's he's the smartest
kid in the class I want him to be
respected because he's the best teacher
in the class because he communicates
well because he has empathy for his
peers because he's always willing to
stop what he's
to help one of his friends I think if
that happens and I wouldn't worry too
much about what my son does afterwards